merci vous m'excuserez de ne pas faire d
transition importante compte tenu du
fait que nous avons une demi heure de
retard et donc sans tarder je passe
immédiatement la parole à mon ami
christian jacob qui fait un travail
remarquable à l'assemblée nationale est
en relation avec les députés européens
et l'europe
christian merci merci gens ravis de vous
retrouver tous ici à menton sur ce sujet
des européennes a peut-être deux trois
mots d'introduction c'est ce que tu
souhaitais pour dire tout d'abord que on
a je crois une vraie opportunité sur la
préparation de ces élections européennes
d'abord pour remercier le travail qui a
été fait par laurent et par toute
l'équipe de direction pour préparer
cette cette campagne et ce débat
européen
on n'est pas réunies aujourd'hui pour
dire la messe et dire voilà comment les
choses vont se passer mais tout
simplement pour ouvrir un débat qui va
nous permettre de sortir des postures
parce que ce que nous attendons et je
crois ce que nos concitoyens attendent
et bien c'est une vision concrète
pragmatique des des enjeux européens et
donc ça on le fera pas dans la posture
on le fera pas non plus par le concours
lépine des propositions mais simplement
en revenant sur les sujets de fond et
sur la tante de nos concitoyens et on
voit bien aujourd'hui lorsqu'on fait le
tour des capitales européennes et entre
autres sur notre territoire national
également les préoccupations premières
on a le sujet qui vient d'être évoquée
par nadine et par rachida on a le sujet
de l'immigration est un sujet numéro un
y a pas un pays européen où ce sujet ne
se pose pas et donc c'est à nous d'être
en initiative on a celui de la
protection intérieure c'est aussi
contrôle de contrôle des frontières
c'est un sujet mais où l'on doit avoir
là encore un raisonnement européen c'est
celui de la protection on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure sur la notion de
préférence communautaire michel dantin
entre autres mais d'autres langues l'ont
également évoqué une table ronde
précédente c'est un sujet essentiel
il s'agit à la fois de favoriser la
concurrence la libre circulation
de nos produits mais de le faire dans ce
cadre communautaire ce n'est pas un
reproche vivement nationale c'est
exactement le contraire et il faut se
doter d'un certain nombre d'outils
notamment lorsqu'on est en discussions
sur les accords internationaux
il faut qu'on ait la capacité de
répondre ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut
sur le plan national pour définissent un
certain nombre de règles je pense à
celles des normes
il ya une position qu'on a toujours
défini qu'il faut porter haut et clair
il s'agit simplement de dire qu' aucune
norme nationale ne doit être plus
contraignantes que la norme européenne
c'est une règle est simple que tout le
monde comprend et qui nous permet à la
fois de favoriser le débat sur la
préférence communautaire sur la libre
circulation à l'intérieur des frontières
de l'union européenne donc on ne renonce
pas à la compétitivité à la liberté
d'entreprise simplement
eh bien on ne cherche pas
systématiquement à mettre un boulet au
pied des agriculteurs des industriels
des artisans des commerçants de tous
ceux qui font l'économie de notre pays
c'est ça que nous demandons et ça cette
ligue là c'est une ligne que nous
pouvons porter et donc nous avons dans
ce cadre de vraies opportunités avec un
message concret comme celui là au moment
où nous avons un président de la
république avec disons le le mépris la
suffisance et la condescendance qui le
caractérise
est ce que nos compatriotes commence à
ressentir de plus en plus nos
partenaires européens le ressentent
aussi quand on avance sur nos
propositions
il s'agit pas tout simplement de
chercher le meilleur slogan le slogan le
plus à la mode mais d'être capable de
dire demain si vous votez pour nos
listes et bien nous avons une majorité
nous sommes immédiatement en situation
de l'appliquer parce que on a reçu ce
débat à l'intérieur du pp 1 avec nos
collègues du ppe est encore une fois un
coup de chapeau à nos députés européens
souvent critiqué regardez aujourd'hui le
travail qui est réalisé par eux et je
peux vous dire que quand nous allons à
bruxelles on peut être fier du travail
qui est fait par nos députés européens
et quand on va strasbourg aussi au cas
où il y aurait eu deux trois alsaciens
dans la salle le mort est quoi un peu
donc coup de chapeau à eux et tout cela
pour dire mon cher jean que les
opportunités
elle existe il faut faire ce travail
comme laurent nous a souhaité qu'une
passion c'est à dire que aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas un aboutissement
c'est le départ ces lancements et c'est
à partir de là qu'on va construire cette
ligne
cette ligne cet objectif pour les les
élections européennes et qui nous
permettront d'aller à la victoire parce
que c'est ensemble que nous allons
travailler ensemble dans la grande
cathédrale ump pas dans les chapelles
autour le travail des chapelles et les
biens et l'ags
mais la cathédrale et les leurs bravo
message reçu message passé voilà et sans
transition je passe sans que j'arrête
parce que ça dérape et un peu je tâtonne
on s'était bien sa part ça fait la
transition et je passe la parole à
valérie que je remercie chaleureusement
d'être avec nous je vous demande
d'applaudir
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous ainsi un moment important
parce qu'on va parler de l'europe et
l'europe est en danger de mort l'europe
est en danger de mort et on l'a vu
encore cette semaine avec ce conseil
européen mi chèvre mi chou dans lesquels
on n'a pas été capable d'envoyer un
message clair univoque puissant tous les
illégaux qui rentre en europe doivent
rentrer chez eux et ce message on n'a
pas été capable de l'envoyer à 27 ans
qu'il ya énormément de travail pour
reconstruire cette europe
parce que où qu'on arrive on doit avoir
les mêmes règles d'accueil en europe
c'est ça l'europe et il va falloir
évidemment contenait un message
extrêmement forts sur ce sujet alors
l'europe et en main et menacée de mort
et d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de monde
qui souhaite sa mort il ya donald trump
y avait là des meilleures poutines il ya
la chine il ya les terroristes
islamistes
tous il souhaite qu'une seule chose
c'est qu'on se retrouve enfermé dans nos
frontières à 65 dans un monde de
plusieurs milliards d'habitants
alors qu'avec l'europe on est 500
millions et on et 27
donc il faut sauver l'europe à 27 est
moi ce que je suis venu vous dire c'est
qu'on n'a pas à laisser le message
européen à emmanuel macron il faut il
faut qu'on ait notre projet pour
l'europe et avec trois lignes
directrices la première c'est que face
aux difficultés de l'europe
eh bien il ya de la tentation de faire
table rase de dire on arrête tout on se
replie on recommence tout refait un
nouveau traité on se met à 6 ans mais à
12 je crois qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement la situation est
beaucoup trop grave pour ça on est
obligées de colmater les brèches de
l'europe à 27
il faut mettre tout le monde dans le
bateau parce que si tout le monde s'en
va
brrr excite italie si tout le monde se
met de côté hongrie si tout le monde se
met de côté
eh bien on n'y arrivera pas il faut
sauver cette europe
pas de table rase
pas non plus de suite en avant plus
d'élargissement pas d'europe fédérale
plus de transferts de souveraineté
il faut qu'on ait un message très clair
on est pour une europe qui protège et
pour une europe conquérante
alors c'est ma deuxième ligne directrice
je crois que sur l'europe qui protège on
va être tous d'accord dans cette salle
une europe qui protège c'est une europe
de la défense
c'est pas normal qu'aujourd'hui on est
con n'est pas une contribution
obligatoire de tous les états européens
au budget d'une défense européenne on a
besoin de se défendre c'est pas les
états unis de donald trump qui
assureront notre défense on est à un
tournant aujourd'hui donc on a besoin
d'une europe de la défense
on a besoin de frontières sûres et
pourquoi pas une taxe sur les visas des
extra européens pour décupler les forces
de frontex y avoir des vrais les vrais
douaniers des vrais garde-côtes européen
donc il faut qu'on ait des frontières
sûres il faut qu'on revoie schengen il
faut qu'on revoie dublin il faut qu'on
voie le touquet il faut qu'on ait des
règles communes d'asile voilà il ya une
ministre de leur européenne qui a eu le
malheur de dire la vérité est là dit il
ya des personnes qui font le shopping de
l'asile en europe mais c'est parce qu'en
fait ils prennent prétexte des
différences de législation pour aller
choisir le pays le plus avantageux ça
existe c'est la vérité c'est les abus
donc l'europe qui protège on est
d'accord maintenant il faut aussi qu'on
soit conquérant on n'a pas perdu la
bataille
on a des atouts extraordinaires on a une
recherche extraordinaire on a une
industrie extraordinaire qui demandent
qu'à être revitalisé on a une
agriculture qui est un pouvoir
moi j'en ai assez qu'on parle christian
de l'agriculture comme des coûts de la
politique agricole commune comme un coup
est ce que vous savez dans le monde
chaotique dans lequel nous vivons à quel
point c'est une puissance le pouvoir
vers agricole de pouvoir être sûr de ce
qu'on mange de nos approvisionnements
alimentaires
donc la politique agricole c'est pas la
dernière variable quand on a tout quand
on a déjà tout payer la politique
agricole ça doit être le fer de lance le
coeur de l'europe
sur tous ces sujets le numérique la
protection de données personnelles
la l'air qu'on respire le plan climat on
a un modèle européen à défendre à
défendre contre eux les américains et
les chinois pardon de le dire
donc il faut qu'on soit dans une logique
de conquête
alors vous savez c'est simone veil qui
va être content et au knees et demain
alors vous allez me dire simone veil ou
la la elle était pas l était pas rpr nom
était pas rpr mais elle siéger au ppe
avec nous et on faisait listes communes
aux européennes
voilà donc le jeudi bowe b j'avais dit
non plus grands noms mais je le dis mais
on est ensemble et on est ici mais c'est
ce que je sais exactement ce que je
pense on doit être ensemble nous tous
qui avons un idéal européen simone veil
disait ça vaut le coup de combattre
alors ça vaut le coup de se battre pour
ses idées
c'est ma troisième ligne directrice il
faut qu'on retrouve une stratégie d'
influence en europe
ce qu'on n'a pas fait obliger les
énarques allaient tous passé trois ans à
bruxelles
obliger tous les directeurs
d'administration centrale avoir fait un
passage à la commission de bruxelles
obliger tous ceux qui veulent faire la
france allait peser sur l'europe je
crois que c'est très important
et puis attention à ne pas laisser non
plus le monopole de la société civile à
emmanuel macron il faudra à côté des
sortants qui ont fait un formidable
travail que nous ayons sur la liste des
personnalités de la société civile des
experts qui connaissent vraiment tous
les sujets européens et qui sauront
faire du lobbying européen on a besoin
de plus de france en europe
patriote et européen ça doit être notre
projet merci merci au jury
merci beaucoup de ta présence et de ton
discours
je voudrais juste un instant signaler la
présence de bernard accoyer qui a géré
notre assemblée nationale qui a géré l
notre parti dans des périodes difficiles
est un ami fidèle solide
merci le savoyard je passe maintenant la
parole à eric woerth
d'abord bravo à nos députés européens
ils ont exprimé tout à l'heure tout
l'enthousiasmé qu'ils avaient pour
l'europe et le travail qui a été qui a
été fait le paysage valérie viens de le
dire il a beaucoup changé dans les dix
dernières années sur l'europe
les fissures sont devenus des failles
devant la montée les coups de boutoir
des populismes les rêves sont quand même
devenus des monstres froids technocratie
les relations avec l'europe et les
peuples sont extraordinairement distante
qui comprend aujourd'hui comment
fonctionne l'europe qui comprend comment
les décisions sont prises
et ça ce n'est pas de la responsabilité
uniquement des pays
c'est aussi de la responsabilité de
chacun d'entre nous et puis la puissance
est devenu lenteur c'est à dire un
capacité de réagir lorsque les crises
surviennent alors face à cela merci
d'abord d'avoir organisé ce conseil
national laurent je pense qu'il est très
important et j'ai compris que c'était un
conseil national de lancement d'un débat
au sein de notre mouvement sur l'europe
et puis après on rentrera dans
l'élection elle même
nous n'avons pas besoin de nous fâcher
sur l'europe j'entends je lis cela il
n'y a vraiment pas besoin de se fâcher
mais on a besoin de débattre et le débat
il est lancé aujourd'hui on doit éviter
les maux eurosceptiques robes et à tous
ces maux qui au fond nous catégorise
alors qu' on ne rentre ni les uns ni les
autres dans des catégories les mots
europe des nations fédération tout ça
c'est des mots qui nous renvoient vers
des sujets trop caricaturaux dans
lesquelles nous ne pouvons pas nous
retrouver
je pense que il faut d'abord réfléchir à
l'europe de la protection c'est le sujet
c'est le sujet qui est évoqué dans le
débat précédent mais là dedans il ya la
question des migrations qui est une
grenade à fragmentation des goupilles au
centre de l'europe
c'est ce que n'a pas fait la crise
économique les crises migratoires peur
peuvent le faire et on le voit
aujourd'hui
concrètement il faut donc réagir moi je
crois à une chose et je sais que
je sais que que vous êtes nombreux à
être d'accord là dessus d'abord on doit
sauver toutes les vies qui doivent être
sauvés c'est pas possible de faire la
politique en pensant qu'une vie ne vaut
pas une autre vie toutes les vies
doivent être sauvés et puis il faut
évidemment éviter ces bateaux qui
traversent la méditerranée
on a la puissance militaire pour le
faire faut juste de la mettre en oeuvre
et puis il ya la capacité à aller
détruire ces mafias dont on parle pas la
mafia bretonne alain les vrais mafia
celle des passeurs celle des basses
heures et ça nous avons aussi les moyens
militaires de le faire il faut créer des
100 des hotspots
les républicains en sont à l'origine de
cette idée des hotspots dans les pays
qui sont des pays émetteurs
d'immigration mais gérée par l'europe et
puis il faut enfin évidemment beaucoup
le disais tout à l'heure
faire en sorte que l'afrique se se
développe c'est une talons sujet mais
au-delà de cette europe de la protection
il faut une europe de l'adhésion la
protection c'est un peu négatif il faut
de l'adhésion on a envie d'adhérer à un
projet européen tu le dis j'ai très bien
valérie tout à l'heure il faut adhérer à
un projet avoir une certaine idée de
l'europe comme le général de gaulle nous
a donné une certaine idée de la france
et cette certaine idée de l'europe elle
est aujourd'hui
nulle part on est on oppose des riffs on
oppose à une vision technocratique de
l'europe souvent des projets ou des
propositions qui le sont tout autant
l'europe des cercles le budget de
l'eurozone
un ministre des finances alors que le
ministre des affaires étrangères n'a
aucun pouvoir
tout ça est important mais en réalité
c'est pas ça qui va faire que les
peuples deviennent européen ou au
contraire ne le devienne pas et moi je
crois que nous devons face au populisme
essayé d' incarner l'europe et on doit
pouvoir incarner l'europe en essayant
d'élever des symboles nous pourrions
faire en sorte dans cette campagne de
porter un certain nombre de symboles
certains en ont cité mais qui nous
permettrait de faire toucher du doigt ce
qu'est et ce que doit devenir le rajout
prend quelques exemples et je vous
prends un exemple qui est un exemple que
j'ai depuis longtemps en tête
l'europe ça doit être une europe
souveraine
la souveraineté des nations mais aussi
la souveraineté du collectif sinon ça ne
pèse pas par rapport à monsieur trump ou
par rapport aux chinois ou par rapport à
monsieur poutine
nous devons peser ensemble quelle est la
meilleure façon au delà d'une défense
européenne qui est un un bien long terme
c'est évidemment d'avoir un outil de
souveraineté politique et militaire je
pense par exemple à un sous-seing un
porte avion européen par un sous-marin
dans un porte avions européens qui est
l'emblème m
de la puissance aujourd'hui on aurait un
porte avions européens il serait au fond
le début d'une politique étrangère non
pas comme une mais pour armer ce
porte-avions pour lui donner un peu de
mission il faut évidemment à ce
moment-là lui dire ce que nous voulons
sur le plan des affaires étrangères bref
ce serait un élément de souveraineté
visible et un message au monde dans le
domaine des entreprises
nous avons besoin d'une union des
marchés financiers alors tout ça peut
apparaître un peu comme inique technique
mais en fait ça n'est pas ça veut dire
faire en sorte que les entreprises et
accès au financement comme les
entreprises américaines long sur les
grands marchés américains le marché
européen le marché financier européen
il doit faire naître des entreprises
européennes
les entreprises françaises aujourd'hui à
sion française ou mondial en réalité
elle devrait d'abord être française et
européenne et ses entreprises
européennes elle nous permettrait d'être
en parfaite concurrence avec les autres
entreprises des autres pays c'est vrai
pour les règles fiscales et pour les
règles sociales sur les règles sociales
pourquoi avoir abandonné l'idée de
droits sociaux fondamentaux pour les
européens
comment peut-on partager la même vision
comment peut-on être issu de la même
civilisation sans règles sociales sans
se dire au fond quelle est la place de
l'homme à l'intérieur d'une société
on essaie de répondre à cette question
depuis toujours on pourrait peut-être y
répondre aussi entre repeint ya pas un
modèle de civilisation européen
s'il n'y a pas un droit social le droit
des individus et c'est difficile
évidemment mais tout ça est absolument
nécessaire
pourquoi pour les jeunes ne pas
réfléchir à des épreuves communes du
baccalauréat tout le monde a bâclera
tous les pays ont un baccalauréat
pourquoi ne pas réfléchir à mettre en
commun un certain nombre d'épreuves pour
que un peu comme erasmus qui était un
symbole extra
ordinaire de l'europe mais qui est
aujourd'hui fonctionne bien mais qui est
un peu datés donc si nous voulons éviter
nous référer toujours au vieux symbole
erasmus airbus inventé les symboles de
demain on doit pouvoir faire cette
campagne il laurent je trouve que ce
serait bien qu'on puisse interroger
durant ces mois qui vont venir les
militants sur ce que pourraient être les
symboles de l'europe qu'ils souhaitent
concrètement physiquement presque pour
que l'on puisse incarner une europe
différente pas l'europe à la macro qui
est l'europe des feux follets c'est à
dire qu'on veut des choses on les fait
briller puis on s'aperçoit que ça ne
veut rien dire est que ça mène nulle
part ni évidemment l'europe d
enterrement de première classe qui sont
l'europe des populistes qui sont
l'europe des extrémistes de droite comme
de gauche
enfin dernier point je pense que nous
devons absolument essayer de dire
comment fonctionne l'europe
nous devons tout faire pour simplifier
et rendre plus transparents l'europe il
faut pas changer les traités parce que
tout ça c'est très compliqué mais en
réalité ce que devrait faire d'abord nos
gouvernants c'est de se mettre autour
d'une table et de définir ce qui ce que
ce qui nous rassemble est ce qui nous il
aurait la possibilité de refonder d'une
certaine manière l'europe non pas au
travers de traiter mais au travers d'une
vision commune par rapport au monde qui
a tant changé et qui étanche en boulet
merci eric je vais donner maintenant la
parole à une députée européenne n'est
pas une députée européenne kiné qui n'a
été que députée européenne à assumer
tous les ministères régaliens qui existe
dans notre pays
michèle alliot marie
[Applaudissements]
merci genre avec le micro tu pourras me
taper dessus si je suis trop l'eurocup
moi ce que je veux devenir à tous ceux
qui nous accueille à jean-claude je sais
pas que où il est passé à eric à toi
aussi j'en sais combien pour moi c'est
une émotion profonde de me retrouver
dans cette salle et nous en parlions
tout à l'heure moi je me souviens de
journées parlementaires
ici avec jacques chirac et des journées
parlementaires qui avait été formidable
et des journées parlementaires qui avait
été le début d'une longue série de
victoires
et bien aujourd'hui menton doit être le
début d'une longue série de victoires à
commencer par les européennes
[Applaudissements]
et puis mon cher laurent nous nous te
devons bien toi quand même l'ancien
ministre des affaires européennes auprès
de la ministre des affaires étrangères
moi mon cher laurent qui ressemble tant
à jacques chirac
je le disais l'autre jour au début de sa
carrière qui en a la générosité qui en a
l'amour des hommes et des femmes de ce
pays et c'est ça qui fait la grande
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes politiques
il aime les français il aime les gens où
ils s'aiment eux-mêmes et bien toi tu
aimes les français comme tu aimes la
france et c'est pourquoi nous sommes
avec toi
alors oui chers amis nous sommes d'ici
députés nationaux sénateur député
européen membre du conseil national
nous sommes ici parce que nous croyons
en europe même si nous savons très bien
quelle pourrait fonctionner mieux
qu'elle ne sert qu elle ne fonctionne
aujourd'hui mais nous sommes ici aussi
pour penser et pour dire ce que disent
les français
c'est vrai que l'europe ça a été un
formidable élan une formidable envie au
début et qu'aujourd'hui les français
parce que c'est ce qui m'intéresse pas
les politiques pas les partis politiques
ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce que pense et
ce que disent les français
il doute voir il rejette et finalement
ils n'ont pas le sentiment d'être
totalement européen
alors dans cette campagne eh bien nous
allons devoir nous même nous demander
comment comment leur redonner l'envi de
l'europe
comment leur redonner confiance dans
l'europe et pour ça il faut les écouter
je vais vous dire il n'ya pas très
longtemps c'était tout près d'ici
antibes
un restaurateur qui est aussi à mes amis
nous parlions de l'europe et il m'a dit
finalement les français y croient dans
les politiques en fonction de ce qu'ils
vont avoir dans leurs poches
c'est peut-être ça aussi la campagne que
nous devons faire commencer par nous
demander ce que veulent les français les
français ils veulent d'abord que
l'europe continue à leur apporter la
paix et pour que l'europe continue à
leur apporter la paix c'est vrai il leur
faut une politique de défense européenne
alors je vais pas vous faire un long
discours sera maudit de défense
européenne je les fait je les fait à la
demande de jacques chirac et à l'époque
nous avons construit et les institutions
avec effectivement les groupements
tactiques 500 c'est à dire les commandos
en quelque sorte de militaires européens
avec la création de la force européenne
de gendarmerie avec la création déjà de
l'argent ce ropéenne de défense qui a
été ensuite oublier que l'on reprend
aujourd'hui sous le thème de fond
européen de défense avec les premières
opérations sur le terrain de l'europe
tout ça ça a été fait et c'est une
question de volonté politique et on peut
le faire avec une europe de la sécurité
n'oublions pas une chose parce que les
français le savent bien c'est que le
terrorisme comme la grande délinquance
ils n'ont pas de frontières et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle tous ceux
qui disent il faut se refermer dans les
frontières dans les frontières de chacun
des pays ont tort parce qu'ils sont
dépassés mais je vais pas revenir là
dessus non plus je voudrais simplement
qu'on réponde à cette question des faits
des français comme des européens
qu'est ce que l'europe va nous mettre
dans la poche mais il faut que l'europe
de façon évidente montre aux gens qu'ils
vont pas avoir moins d'impôts il faut
avoir la notion de moyenne européenne
des impôts des taxes et des charges
sociales
et ça c'est indispensable
et ça c'est du concret et je vais vous
dire une chose et ça ça ne dépend pas de
l'europe
ça dépend de notre gouvernement et quand
je vois monsieur macron qui aujourd'hui
veut encore faire des emprunts
supplémentaires
c'est nous qui allons en payer les
intérêts et quand on voit de façon
évidente que la réduction des déficits
publics bien non elle n'existe pas ce
qui veut dire qu'on ne peut pas baisser
des impôts c'est d'abord à la france de
faire cet effort de la même façon que
c'est d'abord au gouvernement polonais
au gouvernement bulgare au gouvernement
roumain d'augmenter aussi le salaire
minimum pour que leurs ouvriers
effectivement et le sentiment que
l'europe ça améliore leur vie
c'est au gouvernement polonais il
convient d'améliorer la protection
sociale de ses salariés parce que ne
l'oublions jamais le général de gaulle
n'a pas voulu l'europe
simplement les grandes infrastructures
et les grandes entreprises même si c'est
indispensable pour qu'effectivement nous
luttions dans la concurrence
internationale
mais l'europe elle est d'abord faite
pour les hommes et pour les femmes
européens et pour améliorer leur vie
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça l'europe et c'est ça
effectivement qu'il faut faire et il
faut que nous avancions dans ces
domaines et nous pouvons avancer d'une
façon concrète dans nos propositions
mais n'oublions pas la dernière chose
que nous disent les européens et les
français
mais est-ce que vous allez être capable
de le faire vous les politiques vous
savez faire des beaux discours et après
comme on fait concrètement et c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'avec une europe si
diverses avec des pays de niveaux très
différents
c'est vrai que c'est difficile à faire
l'europe et c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je suis contre l'europe des
cercles concentriques
mais je suis pour des heureux pour une
europe de projets une europe concrète où
effectivement on peut avec les pays qui
sur chaque projet concret doit être
avancée et peuvent avancer plus vite que
les autres leur permettent de le faire
et les autres rejoindront après et cette
affaire sur chaque congressiste sur
chaque projet c'est ce qu'on appelle les
coopérations renforcées
alors oui voilà un projet européen qui
est concret voilà un projet européen qui
s'adresse aux français comme à tous les
citoyens et c'est ça ce que nous devons
faire alors je veux dire à tous mes
collègues du parlement européen que
c'est vrai nous avons essayé de faire
passer ce message est que chacun a fait
un travail formidable mais ce que je
veux vous dire à vous tous
c'est finalement vous êtes chacune et
chacun d'entre vous en charge de porter
ce message en charge de porter la
victoire de nos idées de notre famille
politique en charge de porter une grande
ambition
un grand projet et en même temps du
réalisme pour la france pour que notre
pays soit toujours à la tête de l'union
européenne c'est la politique qui dirige
ce ne sont pas les fonctionnaires
quand il ya une volonté politique qui
vient sera
elle a beau
chers amis vous pouvez continuer à
applaudir parce que nous accueillons
bruno retailleau accompagné par
dominique strauss essonne bruno vous le
savez est un un brasseur d'idées
indispensable à notre mouvement c'est
pas comme ça que c'était prévu c'est pas
grave alors marc philippe a besoin de
faire un témoignage et donc il m'a
demandé de le faire
vous le connaissez et l'a été il est
ancien ministre sénateur et il voulait
passer le message
peut-être que la famille est rassemblée
rassemblé puisqu'il fait partie lui du
conseil des sensibilités et à dire que
toutes les sensibilités qui ont formé
l'ump plus ensuite les républicains et
bien sont rassemblés et le témoignage de
marc philippe et est important merci
jambes
j'arrive du grand nord où il fait aussi
chaud chez vous rassurez vous pour vous
porter ce témoignage rapide
cette semaine j'étais sur une chaîne de
télévision m'a dit comment vous
daubresse amis de jean-louis borloo
vous pouvez être à l'aise avec les
positions prises par laurent wauquiez
mais mes amis républicains j'étais
république à je suis république a
toujours je serai et je suis très à
l'aise avec les positions de laurent
wauquiez
mon ami borloo depuis qui s'est fait
très très mal blanc par le président de
la république il a mis un peu les
pendules à l'heure alors je sais pas si
vous avez vu il a parlé des nouilles et
du gratin ya 48 heures ça veut dire ce
que ça veut dire
on a tous dit l'europe du siècle dernier
pour lesquels les humanistes que nous
étions avec nous restons gens à l'udf
fondatrice avec le rpr de l'ump
l'europe c'était le plus clairvoyant de
nos rêves l'europe c'était un idéal une
civilisation un héritage de valeurs
chrétiennes du siècle des lumières de la
renaissance de la résistance que nous ne
voulons pas voir enterrer dilué affadi
par des élargissements successifs
s'étaient tous à l'europe au siècle
dernier
et puis est arrivée quelques coups de
tonnerre en 2001 les tours de new york
et le terrorisme qui apparaît et on a
attendu vainement les réactions musclé
forte percutante de l'europe
et puis sont arrivés les flux
migratoires on en a parlé et nadine
morano que je voudrais saluer que vous
pouvez re applaudir a dit ce qu'il
fallait dire on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas continuer à accueillir de
l'immigration en europe
si on ne bâtit pas c'est ce que dit
borloo aussi d'une autre manière le
développement d'afrique et on doit
conditionner le développement en afrique
par le retour de l'immigration illégale
des africains qui doivent retourner dans
leur pays trouver des conditions de vie
décentes
et puis est arrivée la deuxième crise la
crise des sub prime ce qui nous est
arrivé des etats unis mais mes amis
c'est pas le monde c'est pas obama sait
même pas l'europe qui nous a sortis de
la crise c'est la france parce que
nicolas sarkozy a pris la tête de
l'europe
qui nous a sortis de la crise et c'est
bien parce que la france et c'est ce que
je viens de vous dire michel c'est parce
que la france avait ce rôle de phare
d'éclairage ce rôle qui trace la route
et non pas prêtre la lanterne rouge des
déficits c'est la france qui doit donner
le ton à l'europe mais pour ça il faut
qu'il y ait un projet qui respecte la
france qui respecte les français qui
respecte nos frontières et qui respecte
nos nations ministre ministre du grand
président enquête et jacques chirac
lisala prague dépend de la tva à 5,5
pour le logement
et là j'ai eu la révélation on m'a dit
deux choses le communiqué de presse
finale est déjà écrit par les bêtes par
les diplomates et par les experts de la
commission savez les experts ceux qui
savent tout et qui comprennent rien et
la deuxième chose et là ça m'a fait
drôle
on m'a dit vous avez deux minutes pour
exprimer la position de la france et la
turquie va s'exprimer deux minutes
alors là je suis plus d'accord la
turquie n'était pas en europe
elle n'est pas en europe elle ne sera
jamais en europe 1 n'a pas un n'a pas à
s'exprimer dans un sommet européen ont
défini la position de l'europe
voilà pourquoi mes amis je voudrais vous
dire il faut parler des protections il
faut parler de cette europe qui protège
la sécurité du terrorisme et de
l'immigration
il faut parler de rassurer il faut
parler de conquête bien sûr mais il faut
parler de rayons de rayonnement c'est ce
qu'a dit aussi d'une autre manière eric
woerth eric woerth voit la lutte juste
témoignage d'un centriste pro-européen
que je reste je vous amener non à l'euro
béatitude sans frontières d'emmanuel
macron oui à l'europe qui rassure qui
protège et qui rayonne de laurent
wauquiez
merci marc philippe vallet compris
pourquoi les centristes sont à lui à
l'ump puis chez les républicains
et bien dans la conclusion je vais
donner la parole à bruno retailleau le
remercier une fois de plus pour ses
contributions au débat d'idées
et pour faire en sorte que à l'intérieur
de notre mouvement il soit une force de
proposition et en même temps une grande
sagesse
bruno merci merci à jean la sagesse
n'est pas qu'au sénat la sagesse aussi
c'est notre président du conseil
national qu'il incarne
merci à toi j'en ai je voudrais aussi
saluer notre président laurent wauquiez
et tous les amis élus jean claude guibal
que j'ai aperçu les amis sénateurs les
amis députés et vous tous les amis
militants je voudrais partir d'un
constat qui est un paradoxe qui est
terrible et qui nous habite
lorsqu'on est attachée à l'europe ce
constat les terribles
il est le suivant jamais dans leur
histoire les peuples européens n'ont été
aussi proches mais jamais dans son
histoire l'union européenne n'ont été
aussi proches de la dislocation alors
une question pourquoi en sommes-nous
arrivés là
qu'est ce qui fait que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans cette situation
tout simplement parce que l'idéal
européen a été détourné il a été
détourné par ceux qui par stricte
idéologies ont voulu faire de l'europe
une sorte d'avant garde avancé d'un
monde nouveau
ce monde nouveau c'est celui de la
mondialisation heureuse en livrant à une
concurrence déloyale nos emplois ce
monde nouveau
il est celui aussi de la fin de
l'histoire
par naïveté en abandonnant l'idée même
de protection et ce nouveau monde
il est aussi celui du dépassement
définitif des états nations pour
construire à marche forcée un état
supranational bureaucratique et hyper
centralisé ça n'est pas notre choix
mes chers amis c'est cette idéologie
c'est cette idéologie qui est
responsable aujourd'hui de la
désaffection des peuples vis-à-vis de ce
dévoiement de l'union européenne c'est
aussi cette idéologie qui est
responsable de l'enfermement de l'europe
dans une contradiction
cette europe qui a voulu être ce qu'elle
n'a jamais été une seule nation un seul
peuple et qui a refusé ce qu'elle a
toujours été une grande civilisation à
leur écoute et noir depuis 40 ans il n'y
aura pas eu d'élections européennes
aussi décisive que les élections
européennes de mai prochain évidemment
et nous avons nous les républicains une
responsabilité c'est de porter un projet
pour une europe nouvelle
évidemment tous ensemble collectivement
en évitant les deux impasses celle
d'emmanuel macron l'europe des chimères
celle de marine le pen
l'europe bouc émissaire d'un côté
l'europe de l'élite de notre côté
l'europe qui se délite sur cette
question comme sur d'autres
emmanuel macron est à contretemps de
l'histoire sa proposition européenne
c'est une proposition fédérale qui
datent de toutes les vieilles lunes
c'est une proposition qui a été dévoyé
et rejeté par tous les peuples d'europe
alors oui bien sûr il est aujourd'hui
isolé
pour cette raison il a voulu un
parlement de la zone euro échec un
budget échec
un ministre des finances échec des
listes transnationales échec
il est comme le coq de montherlant
chantecler qui croient qu'il suffit de
chanter pour faire advenir une nouvelle
aurore européenne
alors oui il nous revient à nous les
républicains de porter la seule europe
possible de lui redonner du souffle
redonner du souffle à l'europe c'est dû
redonner du sens redonner du sens c'est
dire une fois pour toutes que le projet
européen est avant tout un projet de
civilisation et non pas un meccano
institutionnel fédéral ça veut dire et
c'est sa seule raison d'être l'europe
aujourd'hui face aux convulsions du
monde
elle doit défendre pied à pied bec et
ongles notre identité son identité
c'est à dire assumer son histoire toute
son histoire d'athènes en passant par
rome à jérusalem bien sûr le siècle des
lumières aussi assumer notre histoire
c'est aussi assumer cet héritage
ces héritages qui nous ont façonné qui
ont décidé en nous mêmes une station
unique et singulière d'être monde
assumer notre vocation historique qui
est de renouer avec les grandes
découvertes les grandes inventions les
grandes créations
l'europe doit se porter en avant de tous
les défis d'intelligence du 21e siècle
c'est cette europe là que nous voulons
assumer cette histoire assumer sa
géographie une géographie comme disait
le général de gaulle cher michel
européenne la turquie n'est pas
européenne et nous ne voulons pas de
nouveaux élargissements
[Applaudissements]
assumer une géographie européenne s'est
aussi assumer des frontières des
frontières qui disent que nous sommes
des frontières qui dit ce que nous ne
sommes pas une fois pour toutes des
frontières qui nous préserve des chocs
migratoires qui ne sont pas derrière
nous mais qui sont devant nous des
frontières qui régule le commerce
international pour protéger sans leur
emploi sans refuser la compétition mais
pour avoir comme ligne de conduite le
principe de réciprocité pour conclure un
mot emmanuel macron nous l'a dit nous a
prévenus il veut utiliser les élections
européennes pour fracturer un peu plus
la droite
alors ne lui faisons pas de cadeaux ne
pas lui faire de cadeau c'est d'être
capables de nous rassembler nous mêmes
ne surjoue en panneaux différence il y a
beaucoup moins de différence entre nous
que ce que l'on veut bien dire et
surtout portons un projet exigeant ne
vous méprenez pas nous ne sortirons pas
de la crise européenne par le bas à
coups de traiter de directives ou de
nouvelles contraintes normatives nous en
sortirons par le haut par le projet est
le seul projet que veulent les peuples
un projet de civilisation
oui l'europe et notre civilisation oui
la france est notre patrie mais en même
temps notre destinée
merci et vive les républicains à bruno
je vais donc vous demander d'applaudir
massivement les grandes personnalités
qui viennent de prendre la parole dans
leur diversité et dans leur
rassemblement